[Music]
tony joins us in los angeles california
tony welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's going on
well it's a relationship question i've
been with my um now fiance for about 11
years uh off and on we broke up the two
and got back together three years ago
we've met we're now engaged and so now
in the process of
getting ready for the wedding and
everything
i come to find out that
asking questions about money
and i come to find out that he's living
paycheck to paycheck he has no money
saved
um and i just don't know if i should
continue in this relationship i'm i'm
really scared of
not being
in a stable relationship and
i i don't know that
i just don't know that if i can continue
i'm really
i'm really scared now
tony i want to ask a question that's not
a money question
are you getting married why are you
marrying him
i
i do love him
but this really
it made me scared
of
like what our future is going to be like
because
i mean i'm already older i'm already 44
he's 48 and love doesn't pay dope i'm
sorry i sound really mean but
i just i don't i've already been married
once before
and i don't want to
i don't want to struggle
yeah
i don't blame you for that i'll tell you
in your question the thing that concerns
me yeah there's the how he handles money
to me that's secondary george um
it's the fact that y'all have been on
again off again for 11 years that's
always a red flag to me why are we off
why are we on why are we off and on and
on and off and i don't i don't know
about that to me i don't know about that
well it's only it's only happened one
time um we were together for
close to seven years and then we broke
up for two years
and then we got back together recently
and that's where we've been together now
for three years but why were you all
together for seven years and never got
engaged when you're in your what would
that be thirties
yeah and that's exactly why we broke up
was because i
found that there was no end goal and to
me if i'm going to be in a relationship
like we need to ultimately get married
i'm not going to just be your girlfriend
for the rest of our lives so then why'd
y'all get back together
because he had committed to me that that
was what our that was going to happen we
were going to get married every you know
he had made it seem like financially he
was doing better he was starting to earn
more money
and so i thought okay well
and you know he has a
he had a big temper and i saw a change
in him actually
fixing his anger issues
yeah um tony tony let me just tell you
what i'm hearing in this i'm hearing 50
000 red flags
anger money
non-committal
you can go to a counselor if you want to
i don't think you're ready to marry him
i don't think he's ready to marry you
maybe ever but certainly not right now
if he wanted to get his act together
maybe i'm the kind of person where i'm
like you've shown me who you are
you've shown me for the last 11 years
that's me but if you want to work out
talk to a counselor i definitely don't
think you're ready right now i got i got
red flags going up everywhere right now
on this one christy before the break we
took a call from tony in los angeles and
she just got engaged after being with
this man for about 11 years off and on
and she's worried because he's not good
with money he's living paycheck to
paycheck and this is all coming out very
recently yeah and here's the other thing
and it was interesting as we dug into
her question and right as we were going
into the break she gave us some more
information that i'm like ah that's
gonna be a no but we didn't really get
to dig into it and she said his anger
issues and so that was
one major red flag on top of all the
other ones but here's the thing i think
i just want everyone to remember and
this is true for anyone in any situation
if you have a circumstance where you
feel like
hmm
this doesn't feel right
it's because
it's not right
tony called us and she already knew
that this is not a good idea now she's
calling with a money question it's
wrapped in a money question hey he's not
good with money we started digging
he has a commitment problem he has got
anger issues and there's so many layers
to this
that are so bad and in my opinion anger
she's way worse than being bad at money
you can fix the money thing the anger
issue is majorly concerning and so i
just want to encourage people you
whether you're a person of faith or not
as a believer i believe that is the holy
spirit in us that guides us it's like
hey hey hey hey hey avoid that hey hey
it's to protect us even if you're not a
person of faith i think you would
acknowledge we have intuition whatever
you want to call it a conscience a
feeling i've got a feeling something
doesn't feel right you might not be able
to put words to it but i just want to
encourage people you listen to that
feeling you listen to that intuition you
listen to the holy spirit you listen to
that because when you have a feeling
something's not right it's because it's
not right and that's just um i i just
couldn't stop thinking about tony after
we went into the break of just what a
concerning situation that is that she's
in
and um and and just pay attention to
that pay attention to the red flags pay
attention that feeling uh it's there to
protect you yeah and you know there are
things like premarital counseling and
financial peace university which can be
great tools but at some point things may
be too drastically different and jarring
to to try to repair especially after
over a decade well if someone was just
calling and they just said hey
my fiance is not good with money
we discovered this in premarital
counseling for example we haven't talked
about money quite you know that much up
to this point we're engaged and turns
out he's bad with money that'd be like
hey
people can learn maybe they don't know
maybe they need to take class there's
lots of wonderful people that would be
wonderful spouses that just need
help learning that's what we help people
do is learn this skill
but on again off again for 11 years
wouldn't commit to being married after
seven years and
anger issues the angry issues got me
george i'm not gonna lie the music
started coming in my ears and i was like
angry and i didn't have time to dig it
back just like no no
no
not right now for sure on the money side
but with the anger issues i'm like not
really ever not really ever you've shown
me who you are um i just i just wanted
to circle back and remind people if you
have that feeling inside you that
something's not right it's because it's
not right pay attention to that feeling
and tony has that feeling you could hear
it in her voice when she called yeah i
hope she listens to it it's a hard
conversation to have to try to end
something like this after 11 years
there's a little bit of that sunk cost
fallacy where you know she's built her
life with him she's 44 and he's 48 and
you go it's too hard to restart but i'm
telling you tony it's never too late and
it's going to be worth it because you're
worth it it's better than
the alternative which is committing to a
relationship that is
has some major problems at best and
scary at worst and um yeah i'd rather
start over than then sign up for a life
of that so i hope i hope she does yeah
that intuition